Democratic senator John fedman went
after Fame political strategist James
Carell for predicting Joe Biden could
lose in 2024 the only thing Democrats
love more than censorship is untraceable
gold
bars said fedman quote I'll use this as
another opportunity to tell James
Carville to shut the quote up like I
said my man hasn't been relevant since
grunge was a thing and I don't know why
he believes it's helpful to say these
kind of things about an incredibly
difficult circumstance with an
incredibly strong and decent excellent
president man he rehabed well didn't
he longest quote ever an incredibly
strong and decent president his eyes
have not caught up yet okay somebody get
federan back on the concussion protocol
he's had a
relapse and let's be honest should he
really be talking about grunge
he looks like he hasn't ba he says KT
Cobain was still
alive sorry Kennedy oh well whatever
never mind Kennedy this new fetman
whether you like him or don't like him
at least he's talking he's got he's got
old popcorn beat on that one he's he's
just speaking his mind he won't stop
talking filter be damned yeah I was I
was a little worried about him I know he
was using an AI program to help him
translate in the Senate I think that he
had a brain chip inserted when when he
was off in his rehabilitative process
and now he worships the president like
there are a lot of adjectives you can
use about Joe Biden excellent strong not
two of them no and and the president
can't say those words either absolutely
right ex ex
ex something I don't want down Aaron
what do you make of this trash talking
well again I mean you know trash talking
is something that we're definitely
familiar with and um with fedman a few
weeks ago he appeared to kind of change
his mind and the new one appeared to be
working a little better but now we have
just disintegrated into uh what he is
now and in my issue with this it's the
language right I mean aside from the
fact that fedman I mean his dress code
is completely non-existent I mean he
wears the the hoodies the uh he just got
broke up with yeah he looks like the
love child of Dr Phil and Paul bunan
with the little knit cap on and
everything he's but but the the language
my man like I is he trying to connect
with what he thinks the American public
is and be cool or I I'm not getting it
or maybe he thinks James Carville is is
a brother I mean he could be he's
light-skinned it's possible he's from
Louisiana everyone looks like me in
Louisiana seriously check it out what do
you make of all this I you know they
they sort of occupy the same psychic
territory right they're B baldheaded
liberal cooks and so they're going to
have a rivalry um the old line about
Carver looking like a talking garlic nut
yeah um I
I I think he actually you know accurate
here um and so I don't know what that
makes fedman but um the difference here
I is that okay car Carville he can say
what he wants but listen Carville
doesn't need an AI program to talk God
bless him fedman had a stroke right on
the campaign Trail everybody knows who's
ever dealt with that and many of us have
you know had relatives Etc you need
immediate treatment it has to be ongoing
otherwise you don't entirely come back
instead they pushed him out onto the uh
campaign Trail and they kept him out
there and that's why the poor guy needs
a computer to still talk Carville is
smart say what you want I'm not on his
team but he's a smart guy and he's won a
lot of stuff the Democrats it would be
behooving it would behoove them to
listen to Carville and not Federman but
in that interview they asked him what
about you for president 2028 and after
the satellite delay and he was playing
with the computer and everything else he
said something like Never Say Never so
strap in he thinks he can be president
well Gavin Newsome will not like that
actually he hit Nome in the interview
because he sees him as a rival there you
go are you concerned at all about the
fedman train coming in 2028 well John
fedman owes Joe Biden because when he
was on the campaign Trail Joe Biden went
out and campaigned for him and used a
lot of his infrastructure to get him
over the finish line and into public
office so that you know he's going to
defend Joe Biden for him to say that
Biden is strong okay he's using the
short stack of stairs to get into Air
Force One everybody like everyone can
watch that those are usually for Gutfeld
usually yes but not tonight uh and the
other thing is he calls him a decent
excellent person this is a a man who
denied his his granddaughter for four
years that she even existed uh that is
not a decent person when you're denying
that fact and it's covered up for his
you know degenerate son who has asked
him to to hide that fact in their family
um and the politics of it is that he is
the most unpopular president in modern
times at this point in Trump's
presidency he was at 45% Biden's at 39%
Barack Obama was at 43% again Biden's at
39% and he's never out there like he's
away he's at the beach again for this
week he doesn't talk to the Press he you
know relies on his staff to make his
message for him and that's not
resonating with the American people no
so he's he is in big political trouble
and I know everyone says well he's gonna
stay on the ballot but there is the
convention and uh Gavin Nome is an
option for them in August one of the
points you made if someone's decent and
excellent you don't have to say both
that's true he's excellent or he's
decent but even decent like C student
like you're a decent guy like you won't
rob a bank but you won't tell me if I
Dro my wallet either like
decent Fair all right before we go that
was decent all right remind her to come
check out my standup comedy shows AKA
Live Events I'll in California
Connecticut Massachusetts uh we're
adding more dates as we go go to link
Tree on my Instagram and Twitter for
Ticket info coming up the panel says
what's good from their hoods hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else